good morning Hank it's Tuesday so I am
very nearly forty which as it happens
mean so I'm almost exactly twice as old
as the median vlogbrothers viewer when I
was their age half my life ago I was a
sophomore in college I just fallen in
love for the first time I was taking my
first creative writing class I looked
approximately like this of course my
life was very different then and the
world was different than - specifically
it was worse that year 1998 more than 10
million children under the age of five
died over 50% of kids in low-income
countries weren't vaccinated and 30% of
all humans lived in absolute poverty
meaning that they survived on less than
$2 a day in current US dollars today 80%
of kids in low-income countries are
vaccinated fewer than 10% of people on
earth live in absolute poverty and this
year fewer than 6 million children will
die child mortality isn't just falling
the rate at which its falling has been
accelerating for two decades and after
very slow progress for most of the 20th
century and for that matter all of human
history the cycle of poverty is suddenly
breaking worldwide how did that happen
and what's left to be done well every
year Melinda and Bill Gates released
their annual letter on those topics and
for me it's kind of required reading
every year because like the news can
tell me what happened yesterday but
reading the Gates letter allows me to
zoom out a little and think about what's
happening in the larger human story
overtime this year's letters written to
Warren Buffett another billionaire who's
pledged almost all of his wealth to
charity but it begins by pointing out
that most funding for global health
initiatives comes not from private
individuals but from governments here in
the US about 32 billion dollars went to
foreign aid last year which is less than
1% of the federal government's budget
but it still goes a long way and I know
foreign aid has a reputation for not
working but in fact it is extremely
effective and I also strongly believe
it's in our national interest like
poverty and poor health are associated
with an increased risk for conflict and
also microbes are not aware of national
borders so better health care systems
around the world mean less disease risk
for all of us okay so as brilliantly
explained in this video by in a nutshell
we know that when child mortality goes
down families choose to have fewer
children which ultimately slows
population growth it also means that
kids on average will be healthier and
more likely to go to school and that
their parents will be more likely to
work because they won't have to be home
with sick kids so reducing child
mortality has huge benefits not just for
individual families but for entire
social orders as bill says saving
children
is the best deal in philanthropy for one
thing it's often quite inexpensive like
many vaccines cost less than a dollar
and vaccination is the number one reason
child mortality has declined so much but
still most children who die do so only
because they were born poor that is not
acceptable and also we don't have to
accept it we need to continue to close
the gap between rich and poor countries
when it comes to vaccination we need to
improve healthcare for infants 45% of
child mortality now occurs within the
first month of life and we need to
improve nutrition not just preventing
starvation but ensuring that kids get
all the nutrients they need that's a
really big deal as bill puts it
malnutrition destroys the most human
potential on the planet because
malnutrition can stunt not just physical
growth but also cognitive development
which just compounds the disadvantages
that the poorest kids in the world face
this year's gates that are also focuses
on access to contraception Melinda
writes when women are able to time and
space their pregnancies they are more
likely to advance their education and
earn an income and they're more likely
to have healthy children and this is
another place where what's good for
individual families can also have really
positive impacts on the community as
melinda point out no country in the last
50 years has emerged from poverty
without expanding access to
contraceptives thanks 20 years from now
when today's median blong brothers
viewer is as old as I am now it is
genuinely possible that both absolute
poverty and child mortality will be rare
everywhere on earth and I really believe
that as a species our success is best
judged not by how the richest are the
best connected among us live but how the
poor and the oppressed and the
vulnerable live and I know it may feel
like absolute poverty and child
mortality rates are beyond our control
that only the Gates's and the buffets of
the world can move the needle but in
reality it's up to all of us like when
my kids get through a diarrheal illness
with just Pedialyte and advil it's up to
me to remember and to prioritize the
kids who die of the very same disease
for want of rehydration solutions when
we vote when we talk to our friends
about what matters to it when we choose
whose lives to pay attention to we are
deciding what our future will look like
since you told me once that bad news
usually happens all at once while good
news usually happens slowly and that
makes it hard to pay attention to the
good news but we still need the good
news
maybe now more than ever so I really
hope you'll check out the gate
in the dooblydoo below it's honest and
level-headed while still being
optimistic which is what I want to be
when I grow up Hank I'll see you on
Friday